on a day when the war in Ukraine took a
dangerous turn the arrival of an
aircraft in Saudi Arabia brought a
measure of relief
on the tarmac in Riyadh 10 former
prisoners of war after their release by
russian-backed forces in Ukraine
the look of delight was evident on their
faces and their number included
Britain's Sean Penner and Aiden Aslan
three other britons have also been freed
Aslan and Pinner were captured in April
during the battle for mariopol then
tried in a courtroom run by Russian
proxies the Donetsk People's Republic
the pair had lived in Ukraine since 2018
but the court called The Mercenaries and
terrorists and sentenced them to death
Aslan told his family he expected to be
executed I wish it could be different
but God will be the one that would judge
me when the time comes I'm just so
pleased for Aiden and his family I know
that they're over the moon it's been the
most stressful experience imaginable for
them over four months first he was
captured then he was put on trial in a
kind of Soviet era sham trial he was
sentenced to death by firing squad it's
been an absolutely harrowing experience
for him and his family and so we are all
just absolutely over the moon
Sky News met both Aslan and Pinner at
the front line in January a month before
Russia's so-called special military
operation began
Sean Penner seemed to know the dangers
if they come across the board we're out
gunned we haven't got Air Supply
honestly a superior superiority we don't
have a naval fleet very strong naval
fleet but ukrainians fight so we'll give
them a bloody nose that's for sure Saudi
Arabia's Crown Prince Mohammed bin
Salman has been credited with securing
their release
he walks a tightrope but his ability to
work with the west and the Russians is a
clear benefit and his initiative was
praised in the U.S certainly very
welcome uh again these are all these
these volunteers who have flocked to
Ukraine to try to perform important
tasks in many cases helping the
Ukrainian people in some cases helping
to train Ukrainian forces
[Music]
of the danger zone and were on our way
home to our families
this is an unexpected development on a
day of nuclear threats and mobilization
and it deserved an Airborne video selfie
one chapter and a brutal war that has
ended happily John Sparks Sky News